bronze has got to be one of the coolest
cities in the world it's just not like
other places the word unique is overused
but New Orleans really is so people love
to go to New Orleans hard to go there
now particularly the French Quarter
because it's just too dangerous and
that's a factual statement New Orleans
now has the highest per capita murder
rate of any city in the United States
so obviously local media noticed that
here's one report from a local news
channel
220 homicides so far this year that's
more homicides in the first nine months
of 2022 than all of last year as New
Orleans makes National headlines for
becoming the murder capital of the
country Rafael gooneschi with the
Metropolitan crime commission points to
the amount of non-fatal shooting victims
so far this year 454.
so this is an emergency there's no
bigger it's even worse than global
warming or covid people are dying at a
greater rate than any place in the
United States so if you were in charge
of New Orleans you would respond
immediately you come up with some plan
to stop the murders
but here's how the actual mayor of
neural and slatoya Cantrell responded
news headlines spread around the world
about New Orleans being the murder
capital of the U.S I do not Embrace that
at all I don't embrace it because one
that is the the data even used for that
is more of a governmental term for that
it's not based on what's actually
happening in spite of national and world
headlines showing New Orleans murder
rate is 17 times higher than New York
City's the mayor downplayed the severity
of the problem
mostly all of them are aligned by people
who know one another not random at all
oh they knew one another so it doesn't
matter if they're dead but the best part
is when she said
can somebody be that dumb and be a mayor
of a city apparently she said she
doesn't embrace the data she doesn't
believe him
apparently they're just crisis actors
pretending to be dead
Landry is the Attorney General of the
state of Louisiana he's just announced
he's running for governor he joins us Mr
Andrew thanks so much for coming on how
I don't think I've ever seen a mayor or
a leader of anything respond to murder
statistics by denying that they're real
I'll tell you Tucker one thing's for
sure is I love Louisiana and that's the
reason we're running for governor as
attorney general seven years ago back
when Mitch Landry was the mayor I called
this problem New Orleans was headed down
this road both him and this mayor
refused to address the problems in the
city we've got a police department that
is severely both underfunded and under
man and the statistics are real this is
not like shoplifting statistics uh this
is not like Petty crimes these are real
people that are dying in the state in in
the City of New Orleans and it affects
our economy and it affects New Orleans
the places being run like a third world
country and we don't deserve that well
I've been to a lot of third world
countries that are far better run than
New Orleans and a whole lot safer so why
doesn't the state just take it over I
mean just call it racism or something
and just move in and take control of law
enforcement in New Orleans
you know it's a great question one of
the biggest problems we're having in
that city is that city is under a
federal consent decree you know right
now in America the three cities with the
highest homicide rate are all under
Federal consent decrees in federal
consent agrees are basically a federal
takeover of your or that City's Police
Department it's something that I've been
complaining about it's something that is
Governor we're going to do something
about and so that's the way you start to
Take Back Control of these these cities
is by instituting local and State
Control in law enforcement that's a big
problem
so the feds took over control those
police departments because someone
yelled racism and the net effect is more
dead black people how does that work how
how is that fighting racism
it's it's not in fact again St Louis New
Orleans Baltimore again all three of
cities that are under Federal consent
decrees those are things that as
attorney general we're been fighting to
try to wrestle the federal government
away from that the one thing that in
Louisiana we have one of the most
powerful executive departments in the
country the governor is extremely
powerful he has the ability to bend that
City to his will and he just does it
yeah well he should because they it's
not self-governance is not working under
that mayor that's well we will attorney
general Jeff Landry of Louisiana thank
you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight